>>VOICEOVER: From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[MUSIC]
>>EDDIE: One of the favorite
pieces that I learned while I
was studying piano from a
braille score that I got from
the library was of Debussy's
"Clair de Lune."
[MUSIC]
>>MARY: The other part of the
music services that I like is I
can always just download
something if I didn't get around
to ordering it yet.
>>YASMIN: I got a keyboard
several years ago as a birthday
present, and I said, "Well, how
will I play it?" So I said, "I
will call the library and find
out if they have any lessons."
So I got a few of them. I got a
good sense of what the keys were
doing and how I had to play.
>>JOY: I was looking at BARD
this morning, and there are all
kinds of books out there to get
me back into theory, and
augmented chords, and major and
minor, and all of these
wonderful things.
[MUSIC]
>>MARY: Most of the major pieces
that I've sung are available
through NLS. So being able to,
you know, call up or look in the
catalogue and see what is
available and what I would have
to supplement has been really
important.
>>EDDIE: I, personally, have
borrowed materials ranging from
Beethoven to some more modern
composers.
>>MARY: Being able to actually
read what the composer intended
really gives you the freedom as
an artist to then give your own
interpretation to that piece of
music. So I really think that
the Music Section is one of the
best resources that NLS has.
>>NARRATOR: Visit
loc.gov/ThatAllMayRead or call
1-888-NLS-READ to learn more
about NLS music materials.
Apply for the Library of
Congress braille and talking
book program today.
>>VOICEOVER: This has been a
presentation of the Library of
Congress. Visit us at loc.gov.